there lies how are you Oh welcome
we're Steel Panther they were here last
that's all good
you watch it down here yeah welcome to
the show while you were here with Steel
Panther okay yes MEMS day were well I
mean it doesn't involve you but there
we're sitting right here and they saying
that's right yeah anyway okay hi
wow how far along are you eight months
Wow when in event awkward if she's like
a nun I was willing to take that yeah if
I want to take that chance weird is so
we didn't tell anybody when we were at
Sundance I was like three months
pregnant and I literally I hadn't even
told my mom yet we're not well yeah yeah
and I literally like walked out of a
restaurant and turned like this and
there was a tiny little bump in the
lorry bumps pregnant blob and I'm like
what if I just like had two slices of
pizza write it up or something why
before they should have been comfortable
saying but it's just like that's they're
saying that Halle Berry like there was
all these photos of her I think on
Monday and she was like holding her
stomach and she had like a little belly
and they were like oh Allie Berry's
pregnant and then she had to come out
the next day and be like I'm not yeah I
know it's kind of awkward but you know
anyway doesn't matter but yes I actually
am yeah then well at what point is it
appropriate for people to start paying
me like at this point yeah you know
you're gonna kind of a give up no way I
could be wrong because their face or
everything is to Sanford not to be pray
it has to double thank you like it's
kind of like you're we were in my place
over the weekend with my we just had a
baby
we haven't three-month oh yeah thank you
and I was there with my wife we were
taking a photo and my dad Mike uncouth
tactless father nice guys Jess you're a
breakfast again aren't you
oh this was like no enough um oh my gosh
was it always ago yeah and I was like
yeah and and so of course you know my
dad's not exactly he's not the thinnest
man anymore he's an older guy and so
when when we went back over to pick up
the baby my Jess was like Oh Jerry
you're not pregnant are you like now so
he understood the error of his way he
did she pointed
I'm going to ask you to I don't we
talked about this last time but about
the film Carla you did that we talked
about that on and it got like a lot of
you played a role and we surprised when
you played it the backlash for you
simply playing a role issued to her and
her husband were killers in Canada
people yeah that way you know that was
one of those things were like I was on
70s for a while at that point you kind
of want to do something very completely
different and I had you know read the
story I was familiar with the story and
I thought it was pretty fascinating to
figure out like how do you actually get
into someone's head who would actually
do something like that and as an actor
that's you know that's the challenge
what we do I thought was really
interesting but I but yeah I do that I
don't need to do that again
I think but um because it's it's really
tough you know doing movie like that
pointed right no no I don't regret
anything my everything is always a
learning experience but you know at this
point in my life that kind of subject
matter is not really something that I
want around me but it was a story that
was told and it was a crazy story and in
just and people should know about a
story because it's like you know it's
dangerous and how did you get into the
headspace how do you do how do you make
yourself be so opposite from who you are
you know I mean you try you try to find
little things that you can use to you
know relate in some way to person like
that but yeah I mean God that I did
that's so long ago I don't even I've
done something real something I'm trying
to remember what I did to get in the
headspace but it's not it's not a fun
place to be
I'll tell you that we all have to
humanize the poor like this guys that
play Hitler and say how do you humanize
this person you're not just playing this
character this this caricature yeah I
mean you know it's funny because a lot
of people who play like if you talk to
different actors who play like bad guys
or the villain or whatever like with the
villains that I tend to love her like
these people who love being villains
like you know when you think of like
Heath Ledger as the Joker or something
it's like he loved beat like that you
know that kind of character you loved
portraying and those are the kind of
villains that I like were you you know
because people aren't like I'm a bad
person you know
they actually don't write and that's
when as an actor it's like if people are
like I'm doing something that's actually
really bad I don't think they'd be able
to exist truthfully so you have to kind
of find ways to love what you're doing
you know what I mean and bring life to
it in that way because you know when
people are being bad I think that it's a
justified in their minds that they don't
really know that's right yeah how do you
play somebody and like because whoever's
a piece of [ __ ] they never think they're
a piece of [ __ ] what how do they how do
you play someone and justify it the way
they justify so you lose everything
that's what's so interesting about
that's what's so cool about our job is
like you get to kind of figure out
figure those things out you know I mean
but just to kind of shake off that
seventy show like to get you out of that
family show was incredible I mean
playing that character on that show with
that cast and crew is just it's like a
dream yeah but but yes an actor you're
like okay cool I want to go the complete
opposite way you know I mean so it was
just one of those you know choices roles
like cool did that and then it was over
and I was like cool what's the next one
you know I mean like that's it was just
one of those experiences and I and then
moving on and then you play a bunch of
other different people you know like
alex is a manipulative drug-smuggling
lesbian you know whatever but I it's
it's great I'm fortunate to be able to
play all these different women
premieres by the way season five of arms
as new black premieres season five is
available on Netflix tomorrow yeah just
go get whole season it's amazing timing
Netflix is so smart because they give
people enough time to like binge house
of cards and when they're going like oh
I need more house of cards or like we
got new or different advice okay all
right um are you kind of mind blown it
has successful it's been on Netflix
because I was talking to the guy I've
read of house of cards cuz I was talking
to guy who plays Stamper a couple weeks
ago when you're not rolling that and
like you guys and house of cards were
the two kind area trial shows like when
when orange is the new black came out
first of all you know I think most
people just turn it on going I don't
know what this is and just write it but
the Netflix model of you know original
series being put out of season at a time
on
Netflix or Amazon or wherever yeah
wasn't really done yet yeah I mean the
interesting thing is like when we when I
first got the script for orange the only
show that been out streaming really was
a show called Lillehammer right I
remember head with that Stephen goes
anything yeah exactly and I you know but
no one there like streaming what is this
like streaming thing and house of cards
hadn't come out yet right so when I got
the script for orange I loved it so much
and the character of Alex was such a
badass I'm like I have to play this
woman and you know for me on material
driven so I you know based on the
material and the fact that Alex was so
kick-ass I'm like I got to do this and
you knew that it was something special
like you just knew when you read the
pilot it was something special
but then you can't you can only hope
that a project you do as the rocket like
success that orange out I mean it
literally was like catching lightning in
a bottle like this show and also it's
just the timing with what was going on
you know in the world at that time you
know II mean like in terms of there's
not a lot of other shows at the time
that were portraying same-sex
relationships that were taking up issues
like you know transgender and and all
these you know black lives matter I mean
we took up all of these things that
nobody was really talking about at the
time and since then a lot of people are
talking about right and it was just very
timely and perfect and we went there and
we weren't scared to really tell these
stories and people really responded to
it and it was just like that thing that
was just right time right place right
moment you know right kind of characters
yeah I mean look at the figure that
Laverne Cox has become just in yeah
national international dialect exactly
not I mean totally and before our show I
mean you know there was a really a lot
of us so and even you know when you have
the same-sex marriage being passed like
all these things were all kind of
coincided with the success of orange so
it I it's rich wonderful it's a it's an
incredible thing to be a part of a show
where it's not you know it's an actor
you know showing up a doing your job
it's like it's a bigger thing and it
speaks to bigger things and people are
very very affected by the show which is
amazing I mean it does have its downside
but what's the Dunson well meaning like
you know because the show speaks to such
bigger issues
you're not just actors on the show like
it becomes a bigger thing you're a
responsibility now yeah and even besides
that in terms of like being in the
public eye it's a different kind of
thing it's not just like oh cool man
like nice show it's just like it affects
people it's a profound level that
sometimes some sometimes it can get a
little well do you feel like you're
dragged into a conversation you don't
necessarily want to be a part of like
publicly dragged in like if you're
talking about trans issue or like hey
Lilly we're just doing a show and then
all of a sudden we're dragging in this
real passion I mean it's it's a really
interesting place to be it's like it's
at the end of the day it's literally you
know the fact that we're taking up these
issues and that nothing is taboo for for
Jenji Kohan who created the show it's a
it's awesome
it really it really is awesome but with
at anytime you're in the spotlight or
you know people recognize you there's
always a positive and a downside you
know in terms of privacy issues
oh yeah but but the show is amazing this
year is awesome I actually directed an
episode this season which was excited
about I wanted to direct the show for a
while I'm like genji give me a shot and
it was incredible and I'm already
directing next season as well so it was
easier or harder than I thought of it
you know I've been directing for a while
and I knew that when I direct them like
a duck and water I just love it and so
that's exactly how was it was just like
God the script it was amazing and
directing these women and I had to also
direct myself and when you guys see if
you guys do see the episode I directed
its it was crazy number number 10 okay
number 10 but what my character had to
go through in the episode and direct it
was hilarious and I can't really give it
away but when you see it but he's
amazing the show got really [ __ ] dark
last season like and it was kind of even
though it was a jail show it was kind of
a fun show yeah and then it was
like not fun it was a dark well yeah you
know first episode last season I kill a
dude yeah yeah and it always just
continually I know like you know you
like how dark the show got just because
it was something different or was it
kind of your area I thought last year I
mean all of our seasons are great but I
personally thought that season four was
one of our best seasons truthfully I
thought it was fantastic with everything
that was going on I personally also
loved my storyline in that and I thought
a lot of the girls got to shine in
incredible ways like a reminder that no
distinct place into jail yeah I guess I
know how much fun watching I think that
we really walked out line well of like
you know and it's funny because even
when were filming it's like yeah we film
in a prison setting you need to have
those moments of levity and I think
that's and like people who come visit or
something like wow you're set so so much
fun and I think it's because you know
and also on the show as well which is
why the writers who are often they have
to bring this comedy in because if you
don't have these moments of levity it's
just depressing yeah
and in real life you you have moments of
levity like that and I do feel like we
walk that line really well and even in
season five like it's you know it's it's
real it's intense it's you know there's
a riot happening and it takes those over
three days and see the whole season
takes place over three days right yeah
it's kind of another whole oh yeah yeah
and it's it is totally but um and it's
crazy because you see what happens when
there's no order when there's no
authority and no order and those are
right you see what manifests in people's
personalities and like it does it become
like Lord of the Flies or do people like
become efficient leader you know what I
mean like it's very interesting to see
the different characters and how and
what manifests in an environment with
literally no control it's another reason
why Netflix is so great because I just
watched I was watching their a hostage
documentary series yeah and Lady goes
the first one was about a prison riot
when the when the inmates take over the
prison which one I I've seen an episode
I forget where it was really have the
inmate negotiator yes and they're and
they're talking and then every start
adding on each other at the end yeah but
all of a sudden because of that
doc you show whatever right now way more
interested in this sort of concept of
it's written riots and it's crazy I mean
and we you know and again over the show
being so timely me we talked about all
that we get into all that and it's also
you know it's a female prison so it's uh
yeah the guys know so it's interesting
to see how these women kind of what they
do so at the same time the the the new
season of orange is new black is coming
out yes I got a movie oh yeah the same
day same day Morrow yeah yeah called the
hero with Sam Elliott he rocks
yeah well Gotti rock I don't know what
this is about it so it's a movie that I
did with Sam Elliott it comes out
tomorrow and he is just like he plays
was kind of like Western icon actor I
don't want to spoil too much but there's
like a love story element to it and they
do it easy I mean and I think this
question will pop up in every single
person's mind what is it like to make
out with that mustache there is there is
there is a love scene between Sam and
Laura no we know in the movement love
interest in the movie um separated by
you know whatever it is yeah yeah it's
what 72 or yeah um but the cool thing
about the movie is like it works like
when you watch we say I'm gonna have
amazing chemistry like he right when I
met him I'm like this was going to be
great we just knew right away and that's
that x-factor that you always hope and
pray is going to be there especially for
a movie like this where yeah pretty
reliant on the chemistry the whole thing
definitely and I you know the same thing
happened with Taylor when I first did
orange is right when we got together the
chemistry was so incredible like this is
going to be great and then there's other
times you do movie were just like oh my
god what am I going to do no it's
nothing here there's no way to fix that
right lack of chemistry it's you really
you're you know when you have that extra
X Factor you can feel it and when it's
not there I'm sure you guys will seem
problematic kind of fell flat for me
it's because you can try to put that
thing there as much as you possibly can
but it just it's missing that magic but
yeah Sam and I there's no way to make
out with that giant mustache I use
awesome I mean wait have you ever made
out with a guy with a mustache mustache
but that money my sense
I mean sales must us we actually joke
around that it's called must acting
we're like he's acting but it's
sometimes like a mustache like moving on
it and he and his hair can we talk about
his hair it's amazing full ahead of
silver fun very very yummy I mean but
yeah it was the the scenes like that was
saying we're wonderful were spectacle
and lovely and you know a heartthrob a
guy supposed to use tongue when they
kiss on I have to aside you know what's
of this and I mean supposed to okay that
feels natural to not use tongue when you
kiss somebody on screen I know what's so
funny is like people ask me that because
the other thing too is Sam's real-life
wife Katharine Ross is in the movie
playing his ex-wife oh maybe we're like
is that weird what and it's like no
we're actors it's like what we do but
the thing is is what's funny is when
you're doing it seem like that there's
so much technical stuff like the camera
where the camera isn't lighting and
showing this or that or what body and
blah blah and there's all this stuff in
your head where you're trying to act
naturally really be there presently for
your fellow actor you're doing the scene
already with 40 people like sitting
around like hey like you can write like
this awkward thing you you really like
the last thing I'm really thinking about
is like is there is there not tongue
happening right now I'm just trying to
be present and like here for you know my
co-star but um
yeah it hasn't really been an issue okay
I was just curious
yeah it's not late yet some of that same
Elliott song it's not like youth young
or don't you know me like I honestly
can't even tell you like I don't even
know directly because you're just you're
thinking about a hundred different
things I have we have to wrap up because
we're gonna get cut off okay we're not
doing it we're doing we're doubling out
okay all we have to okay I think yeah
yeah we do okay
so I want to promote you probably aren't
is the new black comes out tomorrow on
Netflix and your film the hero comes out
tomorrow as well she plays a comic in
the movie I really stand up alright yeah
we Ali Wong help me
a lot yeah yes they use real comics in
the movie okay yeah the comedy scenes
it's a good movie it's called the hero
and you can find it see if it's playing
in your area and it takes a lot of turns
that you don't necessarily if you want a
little unconventional we have Sam Elliot
tomorrow too so we're going to cocktail
yeah he's so awesome you guys will love
him I'm answering the same questions
about making out with you so you like it
yeah I tell him I flipped on the tongue
okay